everyone is fallible this is a message
that really hit me during the course of
my degree there were so many people
smarter than me who idolized and who
almost put me off study because I would
never be able to catch up to them but
what I've steadily seen and the people I
thought were invincible and untouchable
as them faced challenges and changes
that place them at the same level as
everyone else what's different is that
they know how possible it is to get to
the top
once you try I've had a lot of funny
moments studying where I'm struggling
and badly wished to be one of my smarter
friends only to find out that they ended
up getting or worse grade than me I've
had the smartest people I know show up
to an exam having studied the wrong
course material or not having studied at
all because they didn't have time
between all their extra credit classes
I've wondered how I would ever get a
scholarship or job only to watch those I
thought a better fit miss the deadline
or not deal well with living away from
home what I've learned is to never give
up because you can always catch up we
are intimidated by people ahead of us as
if they will go straight forwards
forever
in reality it's never like that and the
path to success is a zigzag because you
aren't already the best is a terrible
excuse not to start